on the 24th of January in Brussels  Parliament is remembering the victims of  the Holocaust the worst tragedy in  European history MEP sr to look into how  the EU can support the defense sector by  combining national research efforts and  funding across Europe with bees  threatened by pesticides and honey  consumption declining Parliament wants  to boost safe pesticides increase  support for beekeepers and fight against  honey counterfeiting the 6th of February  is the International Day of zero  tolerance for female genital mutilation  MEP s are discussing ways for the EU to  help end this violation of women's  rights in the world  MEP s are examining a redistribution of  parliamentary seats for the next post  brexit legislative term they are also  discussing establishing an eu-wide  electoral constituency and transnational  lists  [Music]